We would now like to calculate
the potential function
for a universal law of gravity.
So let's set up a
coordinate system first.
And in this case, we're going
to make a very special case--
although, the general result
doesn't depend on that.
So suppose we have a
planet of radius rp
and we have a small object.
And initially, our
object is a distance r
away from the planet.
This is our initial state.
And the planet has
mass to the planet.
And our small object has m.
And this object is moving.
Of course, orbits
really aren't like that,
so we should be a
little bit more careful.
But our orbit might be some type
of hyperbolic section-- conic
section.
And the orbit over here
is at some final position.
In our eyes, the distance
from the object to the center
of the planet as our final is.
Now because there's a central
point to this problem,
the natural coordinate
system to use
is polar coordinates
in the plane.
And let's just imagine
that at this moment
we have the universal
force of gravity.
Here's our object.
And it's being
displaced a distance s.
So our coordinate
system is polar.
Let's call r hat this way
and theta hat that way.
And let's blow up our
little displacement
in terms of our
coordinate system,
just so that we see
what's happening.
So let's imagine
that our little ds
vector is pointing like this.
And our center point here,
we have tge r hat pointing
radially outward
and the theta hat
pointing towards the center.
Now to exaggerate this
picture, if this is r,
then the arc length
here is rd theta.
And the difference as
the object moves from one
point here to a closer point
towards the center, will be dr.
And so our ds vector, we can
write as a radial piece r hat.
Now, I don't put
a sign in there,
because only the end
points of my integral
will tell me whether I was
going towards the planet
or away from the planet.
And rd theta, theta hat.
And our gravitational
force is minus
g mass mass of the planet over
the distance squared r hat.
So now what we see
is that when we
take the dot product
of these two forces,
r hat dot r hat is 1
in polar coordinates.
Why is that the case,
r hat dot r hat is 1?
Because these vectors are
in the same direction,
the angle between them is 0.
And remember, that any two
vectors that are perpendicular
have dot product 0.
r hat and theta hat
are perpendicular.
And so r hat dot r hat is 1.
r hat dot theta hat is 0.
And so we only get
minus GMP r squared dr.
And that's the first
step in calculating
our potential difference because
U of r final minus U of r
initial by definition is
minus the work done in going
from the initial state
to the final state, which
are described by these
parameters r initial
and r final of F
gravitation dot ds.
And now we have,
actually, minus sign
in the definition, another
minus sign coming from the dot
product.
And lets make this our
integration variable,
r prime, r initial, r
prime equals r final.
And there's going
to be a third minus
sign because the integral of
dr r prime squared is minus 1
over r prime.
So there would be
3 minus signs-- one
from the definition, one
from the scalar product,
and one from the integration.
And so we get r final minus r
initial equals 3 minus signs
given overall minus
sign planet and planet
1 over r final minus
1 over r initial.
So this is the change in
gravitational potential energy
as my small object goes
from some initial state
to some final state.
What about the
potential function?
Where should we choose
our reference point?
So our reference state here
is a little bit unusual.
And it will be at infinity.
And we'll choose as a potential
for our reference potential
to be 0 at infinity.
Imagine initial state very,
very far away from the planet.
And we'll take us a final
state, an arbitrary state,
just where the object is some
distance r from the planet.
Now, we have to be a
little bit careful,
because in this calculation
our final state must always
be outside the planet.
And the reasons
for that is subtle,
but the gravitational
force inside the planet
is no longer minus g
and 1 M2 over r-squared.
So our analysis only applies
for r bigger than r planet.
And if we put these values
for r and infinity in here,
we get U of r minus the
potential at our reference
point, which will be
0, equals minus GMNP.
And here's the
reason why we choose
that reference point, 1 over r
arbitrary state is just minus 1
over r.
But 1 over infinity, if
we use the initial state
as the reference point,
1 over infinity is 0.
So that's minus 0.
And so what we get is that
the potential function
is equal to our
reference potential--
actually, minus GM mass
of the planet over r for r
bigger than our reference.
And that is the
potential function
for the gravitational problem.
But now remember, we're choosing
that to be our reference point.
And so the real conclusion
is U of r equals minus GMN
planet over r with U at
infinity equals to 0.
Now, let's just finish
this by saying in words
precisely what this means.
So if I start my
system at infinity
and I end my system a distance
r away from the planet,
and I calculate the work done
by the gravitational force
in going from infinity
to a distance r
away from the planet-- I
take a minus that sign.
So the negative of the
gravitational work--
then that's what that
number corresponds to.